so on behalf of kaijun i would like to
welcome you to our webinar
giving you some insight into the kayak
ut
nano plate d pcr system
before i start just a brief disclaimer
what i'm going to present is not meant
to be used for the diagnosis
prevention or treatment of a disease
our agenda today covers various aspects
including a short overview of the
complete system
we then will have a closer look on the
starting template
some typical applications and the
underlying calculations for the analyses
thereof
i will conclude my presentation with a
walkthrough
of the analysis software
now let's start with the kai acuity
system
we have the kai acuity nano plates
both plates come in a standard sps
format
they either have 24 wells with about
26 000 partitions per well
or 96 wells with about 8
500 partitions per well in the course of
this year we also will launch an
additional plate with 24 wells and 8.5 k
partitions second
we have the kaiakuiti dpcr instruments
which range from a one plate instrument
with two detection channels
up to an eight blade instrument with 5
detection channels
third we offer 2 pcr kits for either
probe based
or eva green base detection the first
one
can be used for the amplification and
detection
of up to five different targets within
one
and the same well not mentioned on this
slide
are the various sa formats which we are
going to offer for mutation detection
cnv and gene expression analyses
and which will we will cover in separate
presentations
let's now focus on the starting template
for dpcr experiments a very diverse
plethora of templates can be
and will be used this includes genomic
dna
isolated from blood tissues cells tumors
cell culture swabs lavars and very
various other sources a frequently used
starting material for mutation detection
and quantification
is ffpe dna which stands for formaline
fixed paraffin embedded dna
isolated frequently from tumor tissue
circulating free dna and circulating
tumor dna
frequently have been used as biomarkers
and starting material for prenatal
diagnosis by dpcr
methylation analysis requires
the use of bisulfite treated dna
a starting material for dpcr which
usually is highly fragmented
and also upon treatment at rich
also a mixture of dozens if not
thousands of different dnas
covered by the term environmental dna
have been used in dpcr experiments
not to forget dna from pathogens
plasmids and synthetic starting
templates
of course also rna after conversion into
cdna
is an important starting material in
dpcr
gene expression analyses not only
include the quantitative determination
of
messenger rna molecules frequently using
total rna
but also the quantification of micro
rnas and
long non-coding rnas
dpcr recently has become an interesting
alternative to qpcr
in a vast field of rna viruses such as
hiv influenza or most recently sarskoff
ii last but not least and similar to dna
also artificial rna molecules such as
in vitro transcribe rna or rna
oligonucleotides have been used as the
pcr template
now when starting a dpcr experiment
it is worth sorry
when starting a dpcr experiment it is
worth to spend a few thoughts on the
template material used
this includes the purity of the template
its integrity in terms of length
but also its integrity in terms of
sequence
the purity or rather the impurity of the
starting template
can impair the outcome not only of a
qpcr experiment
but also that of a dpcr experiment
there are several ways how this can
occur
alcohols and salts can change primer and
probe annealing properties
and reduce the efficiency of
amplification
this in turn will reduce the fluorescent
signals in the positive partitions
and will impede the successful
discrimination between
positive and negative partitions
umic acids frequently found in dna
isolated from soil
will quench the fluorescence of
double-stranded dna binding dyes
such as eva green nucleases might still
be present in raw
cell lysates and easily can degrade rna
and dna urea and phenol
might be introduced by quick and dirty
sample preps
and tend to denature the tech polymerase
a completely different way of dpcr
inhibition
can be induced by acidic polysaccharides
which can be found in dna isolated from
feces
these molecules can mimic nucleic acids
and will
form dead end complexes with the tech
polymerase
you might have heard previously that
dpcr
is less prone to inhibition and this is
at least partially true since we are
looking on the fluorescent signals
only after the pcr has been completed
a cq shift as frequently seen upon
partial inhibition in real-time pcr
will not change our dpcr quantification
results
however when it comes to a complete
breakdown of the dpcr by
inhibitory substances then also the dps
dpsa experiment
is ruined therefore dpcr can
only work optimally if templates of high
purity
are used
template rna in dna which is strongly
degraded
will show sometimes large discrepancies
between the od quantified dna amount
and number of copies amplified and
detected by the
pcr this is due to the fact
that not all dna or rna fragments do
still contain
an intact amplicon site therefore
larger than expected dna amounts might
be necessary to achieve desired
sensitivity
for instance in mutation detection
we therefore strongly advise to keep
amplicons as
short as possible particularly when
using strongly degraded samples
such as ffpedna or cfdna
frequently
strong degradation of template dna or
rna
goes hand in hand with reduced sequence
integrity
due to residual crosslinks these
will prevent strength separation and
amplification
in addition a basic sites can induce
unspecific amplification and detection
therefore care should be taken that
dedicated protocols and kits for
recovery of high
quality gdna from ffpe samples are used
i now would like to direct your
attention to some quantitative
considerations with
special emphasis on genome sizes
application dependency and the type of
signal detection
on this slide i have listed the genome
sizes of various
frequently studied organisms including
homo sapiens
it might be kind of disillusioning to
see that the genome size of the mouse is
larger than ours
and i don't know whether it gives you
some comfort knowing that the japanese
plant paris japonica has a genome size
50 times larger than ours well
why have i listed all this information
this i would like to explain on the
following slide
a question which is frequently linked to
dpcr
which template amount should i use for
my experiment
given that you even have the choice to
decide the answer is
it depends imagine you are looking for a
single copy gene which means
one copy per hapley genome
if you decided to always use 10 nanogram
of dna as template
this would correspond to copy numbers
ranging from roughly 3 000
to 2.6 billion copies per reaction
the latter one would result into
hopeless overloading of the kaiquit
nanoplates
you will see and learn during this
presentation that in dpcr
at least a few partitions must be empty
which means negative in order to apply
the calculations for templating
concentration
on the bottom of the slide you see some
calculations
indicating appropriate template amounts
of human genomic dna
if studying a single copy gene
when you are looking for the needle in
the haystack meaning a very rare
mutation
you rather want to go with a higher
template amount
when looking for copy number variation
events a significantly lower template
amount will do the job
this slide demonstrates how detail sorry
this slide illustrates how the template
amount
used affects the outcome of the
experiment
depending on the detection method
eva green will bind to any kind of
double-stranded dna
and will thereby start to fluoresce
even if a partition does not contain a
dna molecule coding for the target of
interest it still will contain other dna
molecules
upon increase of the template as done
here
this background fluorescence will
increase and results in
worsened discrimination between
positive and negative partitions
therefore our advice is not to exceed
100 nanogram of template
in eva green based applications
with this slide i would like to explain
why the inclusion of a restriction
enzyme is important
when using genomic dna as template
it should be performed whenever you are
using dna samples with an
average length of more than 20 kb
plasmids always should be linearized
independent of their
size this ensures even distribution of
the template on the nanoplate and is
also a prerequisite for the
efficient amplification of plasmids
which tend to re-anneal extremely fast
as long as they are in a circular form
a restriction enzyme digest is
particularly important for copy number
variation analyses where multiple copies
of a gene
might be linked in tandem it
is not required for highly fragmented
dna such as
ffpe dna circulating dna
cdna g-blocks and other short templates
now how is the restriction enzyme digest
performed in our system
well simply include one of the
restriction enzymes which we will
recommend
directly in the master mix and incubate
after addition of the template
for 10 minutes at room temperature
of course you should make sure that the
restriction enzyme will not con
cut within your amplicon and for kyogen
essays targeting genomic dna such as c
and v
essays and mutation detection assays
suitable
enzymes for the respective essay
will be recommended
with the next set of slides i would like
to give a short
review of some typical applications in
dpcr
and the underlying calculations
in the upcoming month we will offer some
more
detailed seminars on those various
application types
among the numerous applications for
digital pcr
a few of the most frequently used ones
are listed on this slide
no matter which one you choose the
starting point always will be the
absolute quantification of your targets
based on these results subsequent
analyses such as mutation detection copy
number variation analysis and gene
expression analysis
can be performed
what is the outcome of a digital pcr
experiment using the kai qt system
there are primarily two numbers which
play an
important role for the subsequent
analysis
the first one is the number of pcr
reaction mix filled
which means valid partitions
based on the play time play type which
you have selected
this can be either up to 26 384
or 8510 partitions
this number is determined based on the
number of positive spots per well
in the reference channel the second
number
is the number of positive partitions per
well
which means partition showing a
fluorescence clearly above background
in theory this again can be numbers up
to 8.5 k
and 26 k respectively
if performing a multiplex d pcr those
numbers will be determined for
each detection channel which means for
each target
separately
as i have already pointed out the
starting point of
all the pcr analyses is the absolute
quantification
i therefore will call it first level
analysis
after the analysis and the processing of
the raw image data
you will obtain the following numbers
the number of valid partitions per well
and the number of positive partitions
per well
please note that only a partition which
has been identified as a
valid one can be considered as a
positive one
given that its fluorescence lies above a
certain threshold
using those two numbers you
automatically can calculate the number
of
valid but negative partitions
now using those numbers the analysis
algorithms
will calculate the copies per migrator
of your target
including the confidence interval at a
95
confidence level if replicates have been
used also the mean value of these
replicates will be calculated
what are the underlying assumptions and
calculations
well in a dpcr reaction the complete
reaction
is separated into multiple single
partitions
the target molecules are randomly
distributed across
all available partitions
now after this distribution process the
partitions will contain
either no copy of the target molecule
one copy of the target molecule or
more than one copy of the target
molecule
as the target molecules are distributed
randomly
poisson distribution can be used to
calculate the average copy of the target
molecule per valid partition
simeon dini person a french
mathematician
has developed a theory and corresponding
equations on the discrete probability
distribution
of a given number of events which can be
observed within a defined time
or as in our case space interval
our space interval will be a single
partition
now the poisson distribution itself
gives probabilities for positive integer
random events in this case a partition
containing at least one copy
of our target sequence lambda
is the expectation value for these
events and will tell
what the most likely average value of
copies per partition is
in order to do these calculations the
software needs the information how many
valid and how many positive partitions
we see in the well
the equation the equation shown also
demonstrates
why we always need at least a few
negative partitions in dpcr
in order to do proper calculations
if each valid partition were
a positive partition then the numerator
of this equation would become zero
and no further calculation would be
possible
i now would like to cover a few
applications which we had been calling
second level analyses all second level
analyses
are based on the results of the absolute
quantification
types of second level analyses include
mutation detection
gene expression analysis copy number
variation analysis and quantification of
genome editing events
for mutation detection copy numbers
of the wild type and the mutant target
which are detected on
different target channels are calculated
then the ratio of mutant versus total
number of positive events
including y type plus mutant is
calculated in
expressed in percent as fractional
abundance if replicates have been used
the mean ratio is also calculated in
expressed in percentage
let me explain it with sample number one
we have detected two thousand copies per
microliter of wild type
and 5000 copies of mutant
they sum up to 7 000 copies per
microliter
the fractional abundance of the mutant
is 71 percent
in sample two the copies of both targets
are much lower
still the fractional mutation abundance
is identical to sample number one
and we could go through all of those
samples but this would take quite some
time
therefore i rather proceed to the next
type of second level
analysis namely gene expression
for gene expression analysis the copies
per microliter of the gene of
interest in the reference gene or the
reference
genes are calculated the number of
reference genes can vary and usually
will be in the range of one to three
within one sample there can be multiple
genes of interest
or and reference genes each detected on
a different channel
then the ratio of gene of interest
versus reference gene
is calculated if more than one
reference gene has been used the ratio
of gene of interest
versus the geometric mean of the
reference genes
is calculated subsequently
the ratio of gene of interest versus
reference gene of the reference sample
is set to one the ratio of
all other samples are normalized to this
value and let me again explain it with
our sample one
we have detected two thousand copies per
migrator of our gene of interest
and found one thousand copies of our
reference g
number one from this we obtain
a ratio of two since sample
one is our reference sample which we
want to compare
all our other samples to we set this
ratio
to one if we now look at
our sample two the copies of the
reference gene
is identical to sample number one
however
our our gene of interest has
4 000 copies per microliter in this
sample
the ratio now will be 4
and if we compare it to our
reference sample
we will learn that our gene of interest
is
upregulated twofold
the way how we perform copy number
variation analysis is quite similar
copy numbers of the gene of interest and
the reference target are calculated then
the ratio of gene of interest versus
reference target is calculated
the ratio of gene of interest versus
reference target of the
reference sample is then set to the
known copy number
of this reference sample in this case
2 the ratios of all other samples are
compared to
compared to this reference sample and
the corresponding copy numbers
automatically will be calculated as it
is seen here
with this slide i would like to briefly
discuss
two edge cases when almost
all valid partitions are either positive
or negative
so so the basically all of them are
positive
basically all of them are negative then
the uncertainty of the calculation a
calculated concentration will clearly
increase
the confidence interval easily can
exceed 100 percent and certain
modifications
of the algorithms will apply
now the sweet spot for minimal
confidence interval values
lies in the range of one to two copies
on
average per partition but quantification
can range from
five copies per partition on average
down
even to one single copy in the whole
reaction
in the last part of my presentation i
would like to walk you through the
various analysis modules
and displays of the kai acuity software
the kai i would like to demonstrate the
various ways how
dpcr results can be displayed
in this webinar i will focus on absolute
quantification since the subsequent
analysis modules
will be explained in dedicated webinars
anyway
and don't forget absolute quantification
is the starting point for all
subsequent analyses
in order to analyze a plate you go to
the plates
overview page search for the plate you
want to perform an
analysis and select analyze from the
context menu
you will be encouraged to select the
corresponding wells
and you can select whether you would
like to perform a
channel or a target based analysis
this day in this case we decided to do
it based on the target we had been
looking for of course you can select
also multiple targets or channels
simultaneously and all the results will
be displayed in the
win in the results window
how will the results be displayed well
first of all there is the list view
it will display a table giving an
overview of the wells analyzed
this table will contain the following
information
the well identifier like a1 b2
the reaction mix it contains the icon
and the name of direction mix of course
it will do so only if you have defined
it previously
so there's no need to do so but
i can tell you it's quite helpful then
the next column will
contain the target or channel depending
on the
on the settings defined when selecting a
source this column shows then
the target or channel names
the sample ntc slash control designation
this column shows the sample entity and
control name with its corresponding icon
that identifies the sample or indicates
whether the entry is a negative control
no template control
or other type of control
the concentration given in copies per
microliter
this column shows the concentration
assigned to each target or channel per
well
if we had identified within one
and the same well uh various targets
because we performed a
multiplex experiment those ones would be
all listed in addition
the confidence interval uh
shows the value of the confidence
interval at a 95 percent confidence
level
if replicates have been used and
replicates are defined by using
the identical reaction mix plus the
identical samples
then you also could see the mean value
of those replicates last but not least
the partitions
this column shows the number of valid
positive and negative partitions per
well
and target or channel
on the heat map you will see the
individual quantification results for
each sample
given in copies per microliter
below that concentration
you will find the corresponding
confidence interval
given in percentages if you activate the
partitions u
the number of positive partitions will
be displayed
and please note that the number of
positive partitions does
not automatically uh
correspond to the copies per microliter
and below the number you will see the
number of
valid partitions in this case clearly
above
8 000 8 thousand of
8500 available ones
on the the histogram
view visualizes the fluorescence values
of selected wells
and the frequencies thereof for the
selected target or channel
it has two axis the x-axis
represents the relative fluorescence
intensity
the y-axis represents the number of
partitions showing that fluorescence
intensities
a threshold field shows the threshold
value of the fluorescence intensity
that is used to distinguish between
positive
and negative calls there are two ways to
change the threshold
the first one involves pointing on the
chart
which triggers the appearance of a
dotted line once the dotted line
is in the appropriate spot click the
chart
the line becomes solid as we see it here
and this threshold value is updated and
displayed in the threshold field
in addition to moving the line you also
can directly
edit the value in the threshold box
the 1d scatter plot tab shows
one 1d scatterplot view for each
analyzed target or channel
a 1d scatterplot view again has two axes
the x-axis represents the analyzed
partitions
while the y-axis represents the
relative fluorescence intensity of each
single partition
a red line represents the current
threshold fluorescence intensity value
that is used to distinguish between
positive
and negative partitions fluorescence
values
below the threshold are shown in gray
above the threshold in blue color
the threshold field shows the threshold
value of the fluorescence intensity that
is used to distinguish between positive
and negative call
by default the software will set the
threshold
automatically there are two ways to
change that preset for the threshold the
first one again
involves pointing to the chart which
triggers the appearance of a dotted line
once the dotted line is in the
appropriate spot click the chart
and the line b will become solid and the
threshold value is updated and displayed
in the threshold field
in addition to moving the line you also
can directly edit the value in the
threshold box
to apply the new value on the data click
recalculate to trigger the recalculation
of results
now this slide depicts the 1d scatter
plot display of an eva green based
experiment
where we had been using strongly varying
input of genomic dna
as you've already learned either green
based detection will also detect varying
gdna template
background and therefore it make perfect
sense
that the software set individual
thresholds
for the samples
now the concentration diagram shows the
diagram
that displays the consideration values
and confidence intervals for the samples
analyzed
one diagram is created again for each
selected target or channel
a concentration diagram has two
axis the x-axis shows the analyzed welds
and the y-axis represents the
concentration value
for the selected targets or channels of
each well
the values on the y-axis have two
available scales
either linear or logarithmic
each diagram represents two values for
each well
the concentration value which is the
displayed as a bar and the confidence
interval
displayed as an error bar to view the
mean values for replicates on the
diagram
click on show mean values for replicates
in this case
one bar is displayed for replicate group
showing the mean concentration value and
the mean ci value of the replicate group
the few exact values and the list of
valves belonging to the replicate group
you can simply point to the associated
bar
and the pop-up window will appear
the signal map view will display
all the partitions of a well which we
see here
which have been identified as positive
partitions
comparing them to the raw image you
occasionally will observe that
obvious dust bar particles as shown here
and other minute contaminations will be
detected automatically by the software
suite
regions where these artifacts can be
detected will be excluded
from analysis
the kaiakuiti's software suite allows
you to create reports of your
analysis results all created reports
remain
accessible in the software suite and can
be downloaded
or deleted at any time it
automatically includes run details such
as start and end time and software and
instrument version
you can include any diagram as long as
you don't exceed the number of 24.
the report is automatically downloaded
in the download
folder of the pc as a pdf file
furthermore the report is stored in
software suite and accessible via the
report environment
of the plate and with this slide
i would like to finish my presentation
and i'm looking forward
to taking your questions so thank you
very much for your attention